hey guys you know there are many things
in this world that we cannot control
but there is definitely one thing that
we can control and that is choosing what
we take into our bodies i'm talking
about food and supplements here in this
video i'm only going to focus on
supplements i'm going to show you the
top three supplements for memory and
focus
stick to the end of the video and i'll
give you a bonus tip as well let's get
to it
[Music]
caffeine pills
now
please hear me out i don't really drink
it because i already drink too much
coffee so if you drink a lot of coffee i
would not recommend this to you because
that's not really healthy for your body
if you absorb too much caffeine but if
you know what you're doing then caffeine
pills and powders can be very good for
you it'll boost your energy by blocking
brain receptors for adenosine meaning
your brain will be on a hyperdrive
i will add all the supplement links for
you in the video description that i
cover in this video
oh and a great idea is to combine
caffeine with althea 9 because the
caffeine will make your brain really
sharp and the alpha 9 will just
let you be calm and cool
b vitamins
now b vitamins well they've always been
known to play a big role in brain health
specifically vitamin b6 b9 and b12
but eating the right food like leafy
greens will also definitely help
omega-3s
now you guys know this because i've
covered this on a few videos that's
already on my channel
but you can get it from fish and oil but
the best thing
is krill oil
i use it every single day this oil comes
from antarctic krill and is in my
opinion the best source of omega-3 fatty
acids and it is not only great for your
brain but also for your heart and joints
i would really recommend this supplement
because well most of us can't go all the
way to the antarctic and eat krill right
and
these days even fish a lot of fish is
farmed you don't even know it but it's
really unhealthy if it's farmed and then
the price of nuts man it just keeps on
skyrocketing
so get yourself some krill supplements
all right guys for you who stayed all
the way to the end of the video i'll
give you a few bonus supplements
vitamin d
vitamin e
curcumin
phosphatidylse i hope that's how you
pronounce it
ginkgo biloba
and resveratrol
now if you want to know how to improve
your thinking then start by taking all
your thoughts captive control what you
think master your mind and you will
master your life check out this video
and it will definitely help you before
you go always remember
life is short so don't waste yours
cheers guys